you wanna go do something fun today how
about we go see monster trucks
[Music]
what's your favorite monster truck it's
monster MOT cool Nathan which wants to
talk to you like the most
oh the song be monster truck awesome
alright guys we're here you guys ready
to go see some monster trucks
[Music]
they are so jazz even talked about this
for a week you guys do a high five
gotta get up you gotta hook a sister up
there right there alright st plugs
yeah let's do the victims coming on this
all right this is this is Emily she's
getting us our hookups here thank you
very much thank you
yeah let's go ahead it's you're gonna do
a little picture
[Music]
turn around it Nathan
hey Nathan said cheese buddy you fish it
off
a fish for catfish yeah
we're really excited about the show
okay I forgot my glasses in the car
these are prescription so I won't be
able to see anything without here so I
feel like a jerk running around indoors
buy sunglasses on yoga you want to go
see the zombie monster truck
[Music]
so he went up there - yeah his zombie
bones he drinks his favorite
tell me turn around take your arms on
cebre's thank you it's getting packed in
here it's not even close to Showtime
the max-d
perfect oh and and there we go
oh you got the monster MOT Rottweiler
and you got a zombie monster truck and
Emily hooked us up with some tickets so
I have no idea where these tickets are
at so really jazzed to see what we got
there's Tommy I can see Tommy there's
Tommy
[Applause]
it's one sir one
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I
alright guys let's go get some food
shall we
alright guys you guys are food
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they are using
[Music]
Tommy did you have fun bud are you sad
that monster mutt lost try that monster
my man
[Music]
love is his zombie monster truck so much
I had to tell him to stop kissing it
repeatedly and did not lick the stadium
seats that was another issue okay I love
you no thank you
alright babe I'll see you soon hey
Nathan do you have fun with the monster
trucks today thanks for watching we hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you'd
like to see more great videos from the
outdoor voice youtube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every week and don't forget to
hit that Bell button so you'll get
notified when we put out another great
video